mais merci arnaud effectivement retour
sur le plateau de la voie est libre avec
nos quatre invités pour ce débat
consacré à la saône-et-loire rémi
chaintron pour le ps françois lotteau
pour europe ecologie les verts andré
accary pour lui-même et sébastien à loin
pour le front national
on a parlé un petit peu de cuisine
politique
rémi chaintron pour répondre à une
question d'un internaute qui avait le
ralph vous êtes candidat à votre
succession
pourquoi écouter parce que je pense
qu'il ya encore beaucoup à faire pour la
saône-et-loire que je peux encore à 42
ans être utile à mon département parce
que j'ai la confiance également unanimes
de mes collègues de la majorité
départementale et que je pense
qu'ensemble avec le travail que nous
avons déjà réalisé c'est un travail
d'équipé
vous savez je ne suis qu'à un animateur
d' équipe en la matière et que nous
sommes effectivement fier papa 100% de
notre bilan il ya des choses qui
auraient pu mieux fonctionné on va
essayer d'ailleurs de les corriger de
faire en sorte d'améliorer encore nos
dispositifs comme aura attiré encore de
la population je prendrai un exemple
tout est perfectible installa médecins
pointent comme on a déjà de bons
résultats sur ce même plateau
le directeur de l'agencé régionale de
santé disait que la saône et loire avait
déjà commencé à inverser la courbe du
déclin du nombre de généralistes
cependant il manque encore beaucoup de
spécialistes
on parle beaucoup des ophtalmos
notamment qui nous manque sur ce
département que ce soit en ville ou à la
campagne donc là il faut encore qu'on
travaille qu'on essaye de voir comment
encore améliorer le dispositif en la
matière matière d'emploi également
puisque faut quand même rappeler une
chose la compétence économique avec la
loi notre elle va être totalement
transféré aux régions
mais on peut toujours intervenir
notamment en direction des bénéficiaires
du rsa je rappelle que nous avons mis en
place ce qui créateurs repreneurs
d'entreprises notamment pour les toutes
petites entreprises pour ces gens qui
ont très peu de moyens pour créer leur
activité en revanche on en a on en a
fait 2000 créer 2000 entreprises ces
dernières années grâce aux équipes
créateurs repreneurs on peut
certainement encore faire mieux on doit
accompagner
effectivement tous les projets de
montbrison mais écoutez on est toujours
six cantons mais quand on repasse devant
les électeurs bien évident
en que c'est eux qui vont choisir une
élection elle n'est n'est jamais gagné
d'autant plus dans ce contexte où
effectivement une abstention importante
pourrait se profiler
donc notre travail c'est aussi de
d'expliquer ce que nous faisons ce que
nous avons fait et puis surtout faire
comprendre à nos concitoyens que le
département il agit tous les jours on ne
sait pas toujours il n'ya pas toujours
un logo un sur toutes les interventions
pour les enfants des familles des
personnes âgées
les bus gratuité des transports
scolaires qu'il veut être remises en
cause par arnaud opposants voilà tout ça
et bien nous voulons continuer à le
faire pour être utile aux sommets
loiriens des saône-et-loiriens si on
reviendra à la question de la future
présidence du conseil général andré
accary est ce qu'on peut dire demain aux
saône-et-loiriens que si la droite
remporte la majorité
vous serez forcément le candidat on
commence à entendre que derrière vous
certains se posent la question
non c'est sûr andré accary sera
président c'est la drogue galles alors
tout d'abord je suis pas sûr que dans la
tête des saône-et-loiriens ça soit la
première préoccupation très honnête je
suis quand même pas l'impression que
c'est la première préoccupation
je répondrai à votre question et je veux
quand même rebondir sur des éléments qui
ont été donnés notamment en vendée on va
perdre la compétence en compte
maintenant on peut d'abord théoriquement
on n'est pas sûr déjà
deuxièmement on peut quand même
intervenir en fonction d'emplois quand
on fait des aides aux communes puisque
lll sont porteurs de projets quand on a
fait chuter depuis 2008 on est passé de
10 millions d'euros à plus de 3,4
millions d'euros et donc c'est un signe
très négatif vis-à-vis de l'emploi c'est
un signe très négatif
voilà les convaincus qu'il faut que la
collectivité départementale doit aider
nos collectivités l'état déjà en train
d'étrangler les collectivités s'il
département ajoute en plus une couche et
c'est ce qui était en train de se passer
et puis aussi sur les pratiques moi je
voudrais dénoncer qui ont été jusqu'à
l'heure dans le partage justement dz
moi je suis contre le fait qu' on
s'attribue d'un seul coup sûr un projet
spécifiquement plus d'un million d'euros
alors que pour 572 commune on leur
laisse ou bien modestement 3,4 millions
d'euros par an donc il y à des pratiques
qu'il faudra changer
dans ce département et c'est vrai que
notre priorité une des priorités de
notre programme c'est aussi de faire
tout ce que l'on peut en matière
d'emploi pour l'instant géant
effectivement conduit une liste d'union
pour l'avenir à saône et loire je vous
dis qui regroupe les u10 les ump et les
candidats de la société civile
franchement j'ai pas du tout
l'impression que cette candidature était
remise et j'ai très honnêtement parce
que effectivement je pense que c'est un
droit de de sincérité tout simplement
dit en cas de victoire
en cas de victoire effectivement je
serai candidat à cette fonction
mais attention ces fragments très
secondaire vous serez ça des citoyens
d'israël salle mais franchement est ce
que rémi chaintron sera le seul candidat
s'il est réélu haut la personne a priori
oui
alors j'entends bien les petites voix
mais qui sont plus de gauche parce que
ça les dérange que cette fois ci on
arrive à avoir une liste unie c'est la
première fois où on a sur l'ensemble du
département une liste unique bien sûr
ces mecs sur deux quand ça n'exclut pas
quelques dissidents côté vous avez en
face de moi quelqu'un qui mène aussi une
campagne électorale avec des membres de
sa majorité qui s'opposent sur certains
secteurs il ya quand même un problème de
leadership quelque part non françois
lotteau alors qu'est ce qui va se passer
entre les deux tours notamment comment
vous allez et comment vous allez vous
vous positionnez parce qu'on entend des
écologistes qui sont racontées
socialiste d'autres qui sont alors que
je n'étais pas présente au département
jusqu'à présent et il n'aura échappé à
personne que depuis très longtemps
les écologistes souhaitent participer au
fonctionnement des institutions de la
république et et y apporter ce que
l'écologie peut y apporter
un accord entre deux toits on ne joue
pas le deuxième tour avant d'avoir fait
le premier ensuite les situations
locales sont toutes différentes est ce
que vous êtes sûr que tous les candidats
écologistes même ceux qui sont avec le
front de gauche appelleront à voter pour
le candidat de gauche au deuxième tour
ça se discutera le moment venu et je
crois que ça dépendra énormément aussi
de deux du choix des personnes
la question sera posée et l'ailé on est
bon c'est classique de dire qu'on n'est
pas propriétaire des voies etc
mais c'est d'autant plus vrai cette fois
ci parce que les situations sont très
diverses
il faudra que ceux qui se trouveront en
tête de la gauche et la peau leur
capacité de 2,2 pourra être élu puisse
représenter les citoyens à travers aussi
ce que nous aurons porter dans nos
programmes au premier tour donc voilà la
question de la question de leur sera
posée c'est le citoyen sont assez grands
pour savoir y répondre
sébastien à l'ouest au fn la question
des alliances se pose on sait que c'est
pas a priori pas ce que fait le front
national mais on se souvient jean des
législatives le front national avait
désigné quelques candidats qu'ils
voulaient faire battre alors est ce qu
on aura ce genre de choses
non pas du tout nos mesures sur la saône
et loire
aucun accord que ce soit avec la droite
ou avec la gauche comme disait monsieur
loto nous verrons bien déjà la sortie
des urnes déjà au 22 qui qui est
susceptible déjà de passer au second
tour et s'il lui a déjà le des élus
immédiat mais après voilà le front
national ne fera aucune alliance que ce
soit avec l'ump ou que ce que ce soit
que les socialistes même bien au
contraire je me qui sera dans
l'opposition quoi qu'il arrive même si
oui forcément forcément nous pouvons pas
partager les idées que la droite ou la
gauche portent jusqu'à maintenant nous
savons très bien que ensemble on a très
bien vu pour les élections pour les
douze donc voilà ce fut mon talent s'est
retrouvé tout seul donc contre ump s
les verts font gauche ou donc voilà au
moment de cette élection a notamment
entendu le ni ni en quelques secondes
andré accary vous êtes savoir vous à
cette position du ni ni
non franchement là on ira pour faire de
la politique fiction
moi je vous narre les cartes ont cru je
suis désolé à l'issue du premier tour
vous aurez les candidats union pour
l'aso l'avenir de la saône-et-loire au
deuxième tour tout ce temps je vous
annonce un scoop
9 c'est un pareil au vert on sera là
pour regarder si ça se réalise mais là
on arrive à la fin de cette émission
vous allez donc à présent conclure
chacun cette émission dans un ordre que
nous avons tirée au sort juste avant le
début de ce débat et c'est vous françois
lotteau qui avait été désigné pour vous
exprimer
en premier on vous êtes premier vous ne
croyez plus au vieux monde qui fait
encore de la vieille politique au vient
d'un avoir eu un exemple qui ont encore
vous promettre un avenir heureux si vous
acceptez de vous sacrifier aujourd'hui
ou qui pire vous promet de vous protéger
mais avance masqué pour détruire la
république préférant le chaos à
l'espérance vraiment cela ne sont
alternatif de rien du tout l'alternative
c'est vous qui pouvez reprendre votre
destin en main pour que la catastrophe
annoncée n'arrive pas pour créer de
vrais emplois utiles et durable
l'écologie oriente l'économie au service
de l'homme
les candidats de l'écologie membres de
partis ou simplement citoyens ont
l'ambition de vous redonner la parole et
les moyens d'agir pour ne plus subir
d'abord dans notre petit coin de monde
en saône et loire
les candidats de l'écologie place en
vous l'espoir d'une vraie alternative
merci mme le 22 mars refusé le père
agacement
sébastien 45 secondes un concurrent wii
- le front national nous en appelons un
vrai sursaut républicain et patriotique
chers électeurs saône et loiriens
retraités handicapés parents chômeurs
agriculteurs acculé à la ruine
travailleurs artisans
je vous demande tous de réagir exprimer
votre ras-le-bol votre mécontentement
renversons le système ump s assassin qui
nous sommes ce côté autres anxiogène qui
nous asphyxie et nous empoisonnent la
vie au quotidien
on compte sur vous donc tous aux urnes
pas d'abstention
votez pour vos candidats bleu marine
merci rémi chaintron au numéro trois
c'est donc avec 45 secondes
quelques secondes simplement pour
rappeler que cette majorité elle a tenu
ses promesses
elle a tenu ses promesses et nous
entendons à nouveau repartir
effectivement à la tête de ce
département en affichant clairement le
choix ceux de ne pas augmenter la
fiscalité dans six ans chez nous
à l'instar de ce que nous avons fait si
cinq dernières années continuer à
investir investir pour l'humain investir
effectivement pour nos personnes âgées
pour nos collégiens pour les familles
pour la petite enfance faire en sorte
d'accompagner les projets attractifs de
développement économique
on a parlé de center parcs nous allons
lancer également le plan thd la fibre
optique pour l'ensemble du département
c'est un élément essentiel pour
l'attractivité du territoire et pour la
solidarité entre les territoires
puisque partout en saône et loire il y
aura la fibre optique avant 2020
s'appuyant drakkar est votre mode et
bien écoutez moi je trouve que en saône
et loire
c'est la fin d'un cycle en saône et
loire ce département a besoin d'un
nouvel élan avec une politique
véritablement has adapté à la situation
des habitants de ce département
trop de territoire est trop d'habitants
ont été oubliés par cette majorité
sortante
alors que l a des atouts formidables ces
entreprises sa viticulture son
agriculture
et puis son cadre de vie donc
effectivement nous nous allons proposer
une nouvelle majorité de droite
centre et de la société civile avec une
ambition de protéger au mieux les saône
et loiriens à ceux qui en ont besoin
accompagne aussi les entreprises les
porteurs de projets les aider afin à
s'installer dans ce beau département qui
la saône et loire
merci merci à tous d'avoir accepté notre
invitation c'est donc la fin de cette
émission merci au journal de saône et
loire et avoue benoît
je rappelle que vous pouvez voir ou
revoir cette émission sur notre site
internet bourgogne point france 3 points
et faire toute la semaine
rendez vous dans nos pages électorale
dans le journal régional du 19 20 dans
les pages du journal de saône et loire
également
et puis sachez d'ores et déjà que france
3 consacrera sa soirée dimanche prochain
bien sûr à cette élection départementale
de 19 heures à 23 heures tout de suite
c'est le 12/13 qui se poursuit avec le
développement de l'actualité en france
et à l'étranger très bel après-midi à
tous